hey what's Charlie doing this weekend  Charlie isn't a new relationship but  it's complicated and he's also got three  midterms and he is so hashtag over it  and yet it okay all the way dude we're  wearing our matching shirts after Jared  this could be the last time bring it in  I'm not her not her not her nope  okay so I said yes and he's gonna take  me to the nines tomorrow night Emily  that's awesome gonna be great  check it out see a nice cool no he's a  freshman  Oh what's going on mozi how's it going  man  yeah pretty solid wait a minute thank  you happy birthday jangle McLovin so  what are you gonna do after graduation  I mean you got out some sort of idea put  no more beer  okay you're being ridiculous most of the  grave Emily